Source maps through the looking glass
Ben Vinegar
>> Hi everybody, hi.
Hope you are enjoying yourselves.
Get your bums inside, come on, let's get going
with this.
Cool.
I hope everyone is loving it.
Is everybody pleased?
Come on, let's get up a gentle whoop if you
are enjoying this.
Come on.
See!
There we go, very gentle.
Very gentle, hungover people.
It's okay.
Everything will be fine.
Take some aspirin, everything will be okay.
Our next speaker is joining us all the way
from San Francisco because we haven't had
enough Americans speaking here today.
They are here and taking over!
He works at a company called Sentry, he is
a published author, wrote a book called Third
Party JavaScript.
Hands up if you have read this one.
Wow, nobody has read it apparently.
We have an illiterate crowd here.
I hunted about Ben before and was going through
his Twitter feed and was just looking at everything,
and when you see heart, heart, favourite,
retweet, retweet, you know you've found somebody
very special, so without further ado, let's
give a big hand for our next speaker, Ben
Vinegar.
[Applause]
BEN: Hello, everybody.
So welcome to this talk.
It's called Source Maps Through the Looking
Glass and I realise now that a looking glass
is not actually a magnifying glass, it's a
mirror, but humour me.
The idea of this talk is to do a deep dive
into source maps, maybe use them today but
they are kind of a black box technology so
we are going to go deeper and uncover what's
there.
My name is unfortunately Ben Vinegar, it's
a real name.
I work at a company called Sentry, an open
source company that informs you of errors
in your applications, be they single page
JavaScript applications or server side code
or mobile apps and I will touch on that a
little bit later in this talk.
So to kick things off, just want to talk a
little bit about how JavaScript is used today
in 2017.
How many people here use like a modern dialect
of JavaScript, ES6, 2015, 2017, 2030, 2045?
Okay, so most people, then you are familiar
with this slide which is a really simple function
using ES6 modules and using like rest operator
and it also has arrow functions.
I love these features, they make running JavaScript
more fun but I work on a software product
that still targets browsers like IE11 and
I run it through a tool called Babel and it
generates code like this and this will run
IE11 just fine.
I want to keep going because for some contrived
reason I must also wrap this in webpack, so
I run that through this tool and it generates
a lot more content, but of course I don't
actually want to ship all of these characters
to end users so I run this through one more
time and I'm left with something like this,
this probably seems pretty familiar for most
people.
So somebody famous once said, like JavaScript
has become the assembly language of the web,
and I had heard this many times over the years
and I always thought this was something that
Brendan said, maybe it was when he announced
Web Assembly, it seems like the type of thing
that he would talk about but it was actually
coined all the way back in 2011 by Scott Hanselman,
an author and blogger, and he was just observing
that when he browsed around his favourite
websites, be they Google or Facebook, that
the code that was being served to him, nobody
wrote this; this was being generated by tools.
This was before Babel, webpack etc and the
comparison to assembly is pretty apt.
It's not just a compilation target but assembly
is really hard to read.
I do not know how many of you have worked
with compiled languages or even written assembly
but it looks like this, the actual machine
instructions that your computer uses to do
stuff.
Some of these commands are stuff like: move
a value from one memory location to a register;
do an additional operation on that register;
jump to another location in your program,
etc.
I have experimented with trying to debug compiled
applications using just assembly and I have
found this very difficult.
I have no idea what my program is doing whatsoever
and maybe if you are a programming God you
might be able to do this but I'm incapable.
Of course, you know, if you are debugging
in the browser it doesn't look too dissimilar.
My code looks like this.
I have single letter variables, all my functions
have been reduced to nonsense, stepping around
- you can kind of maybe understand what your
programme is doing but it's really difficult.
Similarly, this isn't just debugging in Chrome.
This is a screen shot from Sentry, and what
we do is take crash reports from client side
JavaScript and suck those up into our web
server and give you a sack trace to help you
reproduce the bug but it's not very experienced
for minified code, if you are looking at column
... that's not very helpful.
If I compile a complication and add this like
dash-dash debug symbol on Mac OS I get this
decent folder on Mac OS if I'm building with
LOVM - I don't want to get too deep into that
- but if I fire up my debugger again with
my compiled program and those symbol files
are available, the experience of debugging
is a lot easier.
Now I can actually step through the code that
I wrote, I can actually inspect variables
using their logical names and not using like
memory addresses or register locations, and
it's plausible to do things this way.
So debug symbols map machine instructions,
just source locations and symbols, etc, so
why don't we have this - if we've had this
forever in compiled languages, why don't we
have them in JavaScript or in other languages?
Well, JavaScript is different because we are
not compiling into some intermediate form,
be it by code or machine code; we are really
just taking text and transforming it to some
other piece of text, right, so the existing
sort of debug symbol formats or whatever don't
really work in this world.
Furthermore, when you have debug symbols and
you are doing this, you are not sending it
over the Internet back and forth, so many
format symbols are not really designed for
consumption over the web.
This is a bit of a long preamble to where
we all know where this is going, which is
source maps and what the topic of this talk
is.
So if you didn't know source maps are pretty
much a JSON file and it has a format whose
content let you map file names, lines, columns
that appear in sort of an output file back
into - up to N input source files.
The source files can be any kind of text,
there's nothing about the source map format
specifically that's designed extremely for
JavaScript.
It can be used for things like CSS ... or
other transformations and it's also planned
for over HTTP and we will see what that means
in a bit.
So the very first version of this source map
spec, I'm not sure exactly sure but I think
it was dated around 2009 and was built for
a tool called Closure Inspector.
Does anyone here use Closure Compiler?
Okay, maybe five hands.
I'm actually surprised, I thought there would
be more than that but Closure Compiler is
an optimiser and a minifier, kind of like
prepack if you've looked at that a little
bit, but it has been around for a long time
and one of the Closure Compiler developers
wanted to map what they were seeing back to
the original code so he built a Firebug plugin
and that used effectively the very first version
of source maps.
It went through a couple of revisions and
the latest version is actually revision 3
which was written in 2011.
Six years ago is a long time in our world.
It has been updated a few times.
But something to know is that this is just
a proposal.
You can't go to MDN and find some really fleshed
out specification that says what a source
map is.
It's just like Google Doc that's on the Internet
and you can see at any moment who is reading
it at the same time, usually about a dozen
people, and you can attempt to chat to them
but they are usually not listening.
So despite the fact that this is kind of like
this specification that doesn't have the standards
value behind it, it doesn't really matter
because everything kind of uses it which is
really cool.
Compilers, you know, be it Battle or even
C2 JavaScript compiler, module bundlers, every
browser, tools like Sentry, so we unminify
stack traces, Node stack support is interesting
that will magically convert conceptions into
their original format if you are maybe using
typescript on the server or something like
that.
So we are going to go through like an end
to end example to understand how source maps
work.
I am going to bring us all the way back to
this function that I showed you at the beginning,
add JS, just an add function etc.
I am going to run this through Babel, just
to keep this simple, so from Babel I can just
say: hey, take add.JS, take this file, I'm
using this ES2015 pre-set to target a particular
set of browsers, and then also specify this
source maps configuration.
If I run that command a couple of things are
going to happen.
My file is going to be modified a little bit,
and also I get a source map file but before
I jump to that source map file let's take
a look at the output file and at dys.js.
It's pretty much the same except with one
key addition which is it adds this line to
the end of the file which is this source mapping
URL directive.
This is the thing that tells browsers and
other tools where to find the source map file
that is associated with this JavaScript file.
So browser downloads your JavaScript file,
goes to the very end, looks for the last comment
and goes, "Aha, I need to add JS.map", and
that is relative.
It doesn't have to be relative, you can specify
a full path and that's where the browser will
download it from.
A lot of people talk to me that they want
to use source maps but don't want to expose
[audio problem] ... can have your source mapping
URL point to a location that's maybe only
accessible on a private network so you can
download it and other interlopers can't.
You could even host those files locally on
your own little web server, so you can point
back at local host and you will be able to
download that file.
Another thing that not everybody is aware
of is you don't have to use this source mapping
URL directive.
There's a header called source map that you
can send down with your file that is a clue
to your browser where to find these source
maps, but not everybody has the power to just
arbitrarily change headers.
Again, I mentioned CSS earlier.
It doesn't strictly have to be this // comment;
you can also use this CSS comment at the end
of your file too.
If you want to get started with source maps
and just want to use them, this is pretty
much all you need to do.
You use tools, generate a source map file,
put them on your web server, the browser will
download them and now when you start debugging
you get to step 3.
That's pretty cool, that's it.
So I would recommend doing that.
Similarly, Sentry, we kind of act like a browser.
We actually when we see stack traces that
have JavaScript files in them, will actually
try to fetch those JavaScript files and if
we see that there's a source map header or
a source mapping URL directive we will download
that source map and will apply it to your
stack trace and try to show you the original
file, the line and the column, and we even
pull surrounding source code too, which is
kind of cool, so in this case this is actually
an example from our live application with
some JSX and that's kind of neat.
But we are going to go a little bit deeper
because I think it's interesting just to understand
how does a source map even work.
How many people here have like tried to open
a production source map in their text editor?
Okay, was that a good experience?
No, okay.
Typically this is what happens to me which
is like my editor pretty much crashes, and
they say because source maps can get really
big.
It's totally normal for them to be megabytes
in size.
We've seen source maps as large as 30 megabytes
which is pretty absurd.
The reason we started this with a contrived
simple example is that this entire source
map can fit in one slide so this is what a
source map looks like.
I've pushed around the white space a bit so
you can read it easier and we will go through
all the pieces of this really quickly.
So the very first piece is just a version
spring, a clue to the browser what version
am I dealing with.
As we learned early version 3 is pretty much
the latest.
So pretty much everything says version 3.
What file is associated with this, what is
this source map for?
In this case it's add.js.
It's associated with one file.
Sources are a list of input files that went
into this output file.
In our case it's a single file, but if this
had many components, modules, you can imagine
this could be dozens, maybe even hundreds
or a thousand files.
Sources content, this is like an optional
feature of source maps.
Babel inlines all our code into the source
map for convenience, and you don't have to
do this but this is also what contributes
to source as being so large but it's convenient
because it works out of the box.
You don't have to deal with other problems
like where do you find all of these other
source files.
Lastly, this is the biggest part of what makes
a source map a source map, which is this big
mappings blob.
It kind of looks like a bunch of nonsense
but it isn't and we are going to walk through
actually translating something by hand, just
so you understand what is taking place.
So one thing to know is that when you are
doing source map parsers, they work through
a source map or this mappings property linearly.
They start at the very beginning and the very
beginning represents line 0.
It's not like random access, you can't go
to the middle of this blob, you have to process
the whole thing in order.
So each semicolon denotes a new line so we
start at line zero and you will notice that
this source map actually begins with five
semicolons and that may seem kind of weird.
The reason for that is that Babel outputs
some sort of preamble to the output file for
which there's actually like no matching code
or input file and the source map basically
recognises that.
It's like: hey, just skip over this because
there's nothing for us to even point to here.
So if we continue, we go past those first
opening lines, and we get to what's called
a segment.
Segments are comma separated and these are
the things that actually make the translation
from your output source to your input source.
Segments are made of variable length quantities.
Now, what is QA - maybe that's an L or an
I, I'm not sure - GB.
So it's a variable length quantity called
VOQ.
This is sort of a format that's designed for
efficiently encoding arbitrarily large integers.
It's a little different and was designed for
midi files which is interesting.
So for single characters this is fine, but
as you get larger, 123 is only three characters,
123456789, five characters, or six, so if
it's plain text and we've got to download
it we want to represent that in as small a
format as possible.
What is actually neat about VOQ is arbitrary
lengths can also be included efficiently.
That's the last digit at the bottom.
It's represented by these five characters
so we get to avoid commas and the negative
prefix which is pretty cool.
The specifics of how to actually convert these,
I don't really know.
I just let this library called VOQ which you
can install to decode them and that's how
I work through a lot of these problems.
So let's go back to this QAIGB.
If I decode this I get 80416 so what does
that mean?
Once you break it down it's pretty simple.
This is where now the source map starts to
make sense.
The very first value is the column in our
output file, add.js, and remember because
we are working linearly we already know what
the line number is, which is like line 5.
The second value is indexing [sound problem]
array.
We only have a single array so it's 0.
Then the final are the input and the input
source file, so if I convert this, this is
basically what this segment is trying to tell
us.
We are currently on column 5 line 9 of add.js.
For this one it's column 5, line 17 and if
I break this down and go back to my input
and output file, it's saying in the output
file add is over here and in my input file
add is over there.
That's pretty much how this works.
Source maps really just - they could be character
by character, there's nothing that would stop
you from doing this but we only need to source
map the start locations of identifiers.
That's efficient because if we mapped every
single character this mappings property would
be gigantic but if we only have to do identifiers,
it's much smaller so I am only going to convert
one more value just to kind of bring this
idea home.
The very next value, the very next segment
if you can see it is actually just a capital
G which is a little confusing because it's
like: wait a minute, didn't I need four values
to translate something?
What am I going to do with this single value
which is actually a 8?
Oh, actually I think it's a 3.
I may have messed this up.
So segment values are relative.
This is sort of like a space-saving kind of
idea, right, like I don't need to have the
absolute value for every single segment.
I can just work off what I was doing in the
last segment so if we just add this value
to the previous segment and we get a new location
which is 11 instead of character 8 - bear
with me, this is a little confusing - but
the idea is there was another identifier add.
Add appears twice, right?
So this is actually linking back to the same
location.
Remember, the very first value is the location
in the output file, right, so line 5, line
17, like that didn't change.
So what's really happening here is that the
source map is telling us that this add function
appears twice in the file, which is kind of
interesting.
So hopefully you have a basic understanding
of how this is going.
I would just keep working through these values,
keep translating them, keep getting new translations,
but the idea here is that I finish in a place
where I basically take all these values and
I dump them into some data structure like
a table so that going forward I don't actually
look at the source map; I just kind of like
query this table for the data.
This is how Web Inspector works, other tools,
Sentry etc, work.
They just munch through a source map, generate
this big lookup table and then the rest is
- just kind of works by itself.
It seems like a lot to take in but the good
news is you don't ever really need to know
the particulars of how this works.
I just wanted to explain what is happening
because it's kind of neat.
There is a tool called source-map, it's on
npm, it's from Mozilla, and it does what we
just did, breaks down the source map and provides
an API where you can look up the location
for yourself.
The API is a little complex because it does
a lot but it looks like this.
I import this library, I read my source map
file from the file system, I then create what's
called a source map consumer, and then I can
look up, you know, original position for line
6, column 0, whatever I want to look up and
it will tell me which file, what line, what
column, so if you are working with source
maps and you've ever struggled with - it seems
like the lines and columns don't match up
exactly the way that you wanted, I recommend
using this library to look up the values yourself
to see if they make sense.
That can spare a lot of time with debugging.
So this kind of takes me to the end.
What do we learn?
It's a bit of a wrap-up.
So source maps are kind of debug symbols for
the web.
That's close enough.
They are just files, lines and columns.
They are designed for efficient transmission
over HTTP, that's why there's these relative
segments, etc, and the cool thing is that
almost everything supports them today so if
you are not using them, you should be using
them.
So again, my name is Ben Vinegar, I hope that
you've found this talk vaguely illuminating.
If you want to find me, this is me on the
Internet.
This is a link to pretty much everything we
talked to today.
Please check out Sentry, it's really helpful
and it's open source and you can run it on
your own server.
Thank you.
[Applause]
>> Thank you so, so much to Ben for that.